HOW DID IT GET THERE?
WHO BOUGHT IT?
LET'S GO "OUTFRONT."
I'M POPPY HARLOW IN FOR ERIN
BURNETT.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S ATTORNEYS
DOWNPLAYING THE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS SEIZED FROM
MAR-A-LAGO.
THAT COMPARISON TO AN OVERDUE
LIBRARY BOOK MADE BY TRUMP'S NEW
LAWYER, FLORIDA'S FORMER
SOLICITOR GENERAL.
DURING THE SEARCH OF TRUMP'S
HOME, THE FBA SEIZED 33 BOXES,
WHICH INCLUDED MORE THAN 100
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS, WHICH WERE
MARKED CONFIDENTIAL, SECRET AND
ALSO TOP SECRET.
THAT IS ON TOP OF 15 BOXES THAT
TRUMP'S TEAM TURNED OVER IN
JANUARY WHERE THERE WERE 184
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
THEY REITERATED THE TRUMP FOR A
SPECIAL MASTER TO EXAMINE THE
DOCUMENTS SEIZED.
THE JUDGE IN ALL OF THIS DID
TODAY STOP SHORT OF MAKING A
FINAL DECISION AT THE HEARING.
WE COULD GET HER RULING ON THAT
ANY MINUTE.
WE COULD SOON LEARN MORE ABOUT
WHAT THE FBI TOOK IN THOSE BOXES
FROM TRUMP'S HOME LAST MONTH.
THE JUDGE SAID SHE'S THINKING
ABOUT PUBLICALLY RELEASING A
MORE DETAILED LIST OF WHAT WAS
TAKEN FROM MAR-A-LAGO.
THIS ALL COMES AS THERE IS NEWS
ON ANOTHER JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
INVESTIGATION INVOLVING TRUMP.
THE DOJ'S PROBE INTO JANUARY 6.
WE ARE LEARNING THE TRUMP'S
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL, PAT
CIPOLLONE AND HIS FORMER DEPUTY
ARE EXPECTED TO APPEAR BEFORE A
GRAND JURY TOMORROW.
CIPOLLONE HAS BEEN INTERVIEWED
ABOUT THE DOCUMENTS AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
THEY HAVE TESTIFIED BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS WITH THE JANUARY 6
COMMITTEE.
LET'S BEGIN THERE.
EVAN PEREZ IS IN WASHINGTON.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE HEARING?
>> Reporter: IT WAS ABOUT A TWO
HOUR HEARING.
THE JUDGE MADE CLEAR THAT SHE'S
THINKING ABOUT APPOINTING THIS
SPECIAL MASTER.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT DISAGREES
WITH THAT.
THEY SAY THAT THERE IS NO NEED
FOR APPOINTING A SPECIAL MASTER.
THEY POINTED OUT THAT THIS
SPECIAL -- THIS SEPARATE TEAM OF
LAWYERS THAT IS NOT CONNECTED TO
THE INVESTIGATION HAS GONE
THROUGH THESE DOCUMENTS, HAS
SEPARATED ABOUT MORE THAN 500
PAGES OF DOCUMENTS THAT COULD
HAVE SOME KIND OF
ATTORNEY/CLIENT PRIVILEGE
MATERIAL.
THEY HAVE REMOVED THAT.
THEY HAVE A PROCEDURE SET UP TO
REVIEW THAT INFORMATION.
SHE, HOWEVER, SEEMS TO THINK --
SHE SAID IN COURT, WHAT WOULD BE
THE HARM TO HAVE A THIRD PARTY
COME AND LOOK AT THESE
DOCUMENTS, NOT ONLY FOR
ATTORNEY/CLIENT PRIVILEGE BUT
SHE SAID THAT SHE -- THIS ISSUE
OF EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE, WHICH
THE FORMER PRESIDENT SAYS HE
STILL HAS, EVEN THOUGH HE IS NOT
PRESIDENT, SOMETHING THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT BY THE WAY IS
DISAGREEING WITH.
SHE SAYS THAT THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT IS NOT SETTLED LAW.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT SHE IS
OBVIOUSLY STILL CONSIDERING.
AS YOU POINTED OUT, SHE SAID
SHE'S GOING TO -- IF SHE
APPOINTS A SPECIAL MASTER, SHE'S
GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, THE FBI
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THOSE
DOCUMENTS DURING THE TIME THAT
THAT IS BEING REVIEWED.
BUT SHE SAID THAT POTENTIALLY
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY WOULD
STILL BE ABLE TO DO THEIR DAMAGE
ASSESSMENT, THEIR REVIEW OF THE
DOCUMENTS WHICH IS SOMETHING
THAT OBVIOUSLY IS VERY IMPORTANT
FROM A NATIONAL SECURITY
PERSPECTIVE.
>> NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
HER RULING IN THIS COULD COME IN
A LITTLE BIT.
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR THE
REPORTING FROM WASHINGTON.
>>> RYAN GOODMAN, CO-EDITOR AND
CHIEF OF THE JUST SECURITY LEGAL
BLOG AND A PROFESSOR OF LAW NYU
AND ALLEN HONIG.
LET'S BEGIN WITH THE LEGAL
ARGUMENT THAT TRUMP'S TEAM MADE
THAT CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS ARE
ESSENTIALLY LIKE A, QUOTE,
OVERDUE LIBRARY BOOK.
>> IT'S A STARTLING SUGGESTION.
IT'S VERY CAVALIER WHEN WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT THE NATION'S MOST
HEAVILY GUARDED SECRETS, THE
MOST HIGHLY CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION, HIGHER THAN TOP
SECRET.
THEY ARE BEING PLACED IN AN
ENVIRONMENT THAT'S VERY
INSECURE, A RESORT, SUBJECT TO
PUBLIC COMING IN AND OUT, WHERE
IT ALSO MEANS THAT THE
INTELLIGENT COMMUNITY IS ENGAGED
IN A DAMAGE ASSESSMENT TO SEE
WHETHER OR NOT THIS IMPLICATES
THE U.S. NATIONAL SECURITY HUMAN
SOURCES WHOSE LIVES MAY BE IN
DANGER, SURVEILLANCE PROGRAMS
THAT MIGHT HAVE TO BE SUSPENDED
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO ASSUME
THEY'RE COMPROMISED.
I THINK IT'S AN UNFORTUNATE
STATEMENT TO PUT IT MILDLY.
IT'S NOT JUST RECEIVING A NOTE
FROM YOUR LIBRARIAN.
IT'S A GRAND JURY SUBPOENA WHICH
THEY SEEM TO HAVE DISOBEYED.
IT'S SOMETHING OF A MUCH GREATER
MAGNITUDE.
>> IT'S INTERESTING THAT THEY
MADE THAT ARGUMENT, WHICH IS NOT
EVEN A LEGAL ARGUMENT TO MAKE.
DIDN'T ADDRESS ONE OF TRUMP'S
KEY DEFENSES.
THEY DIDN'T EVEN GET INTO THAT.
ONE OF TRUMP'S LAWYERS IN THIS
ARGUED TODAY IN COURT THAT THE
GOVERNMENT IS THE, QUOTE, LATEST
BOOGIE MAN THAT A SPECIAL MASTER
WOULD NEED SECURITY CLEARANCE
AND, THEREFORE, IT COULD TAKE A
WHILE.
IF THEY GET IT -- IF TRUMP'S
TEAM GETS THIS SPECIAL MASTER,
WHETHER HE WOULD NEED VERY HIGH
SECURITY CLEARANCE, THIS IS WHAT
THEY ARE ASKING FOR, HOW MUCH
WOULD THAT SLOW DOWN THE DOJ'S
CASE?
>> THAT'S DOJ'S MAIN ARGUMENT,
THAT TO IMPOSE A SPECIAL MASTER
WILL SLOW US DOWN, GUM UP THE
WORKS.
WE HAVE TO SETTLE ON WHO WILL BE
THE SPECIAL MASTER.
THAT PERSON WILL HAVE TO BE
CLEARED AND THEY WILL HAVE TO DO
THE REVIEW.
I THINK IF THE JUDGE ORDERS A
SPECIAL MASTER, SHE WILL TAKE
SPECIFIC STEPS TO TRY TO MAKE
THIS AS STREAMLINED AS POSSIBLE.
DOJ ARGUED IN THEIR BRIEF, IF
YOU DO ORDER A SPECIAL MASTER,
WE DON'T WANT YOU TO DO THAT,
BUT PLEASE ORDER US TO GET THIS
DONE WITHIN REALLY BY THE END OF
SEPTEMBER.
I THINK THE COUNTER ARGUMENT
FROM TRUMP'S PEOPLE IS, IT'S
WORTH IT.
IT'S WORTH IT IF THERE'S MORE
BUREAUCRACY.
THERE'S DELAY BECAUSE WE'RE
TRYING TO PROTECT A PERSON'S
INTERESTS AND RIGHTS.
WE WANT THE AMERICAN PUBLIC TO
BE ASSURED THAT HIS RIGHTS RR
WERE FULLY PROJECTED.
THAT'S THE COMPETING ARGUMENTS
WE HEARD TODAY.
>> THE JUDGE IS GOING TO LET
EITHER WAY THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY KEEP GOING THROUGH
THESE MATERIALS.
HOWEVER, SHE DID INDICATE THAT
SHE MAY TEMPORARILY BLOCK THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT FROM
ACCESSING THOSE MATERIALS IN ITS
CRIMINAL PROBE WHILE THE SPECIAL
MASTER, IF THEY GET ONE, DOES
THEIR JOB.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> IT'S REALLY PERPLEXING.
IT'S SO HARD TO EVEN SEE HOW
THIS COULD BE WRAPPED UP IN
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE, WHICH HE
SUGGESTED THAT WOULD BE THE
SCOPE OF THE REVIEW.
THEREFORE, DENY EXECUTIVE
MATERIALS TO THE EXERTIVE
BRANCH.
THAT'S NOT HOW EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE WORKS.
IT'S WHETHER CERTAIN MATERIALS
GO TO CONGRESS OR TO COURTS OR
THE PUBLIC.
THAT PART IS A NON-STARTER IN
TERMS OF HOW THE LEGAL THEORY
WORKS.
THE SECOND PART IS, WHAT DOES IT
MEAN?
HOW IS IT WORKABLE YOU SHARE
WITH ONE PART OF THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH TO CONDUCT AN
INTELLIGENCE REVIEW AND NOT THE
OTHER, THE FBI, WHICH IS A PART
OF THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
THAT NEEDS TO DO DAMAGE
ASSESSMENT?
I DON'T THINK SHE CAN WRITE IT
THAT WAY.
WHEN SHE GOES BACK AND TRIES TO
WRITE THE ORDER THAT WAY, I HOPE
THAT SOMETHING ELSE WILL PREVAIL
AND SHE WON'T TRY TO GO DOWN
THAT PATH.
IT DOESN'T SEEM WORKABLE.
IT'S NOT WHAT EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE IS ABOUT.
>> TRUMP'S LAWYER TODAY IN THIS
HEARING ALSO ARGUING THAT
APPOINTING A SPECIAL MASTER
WOULD RESTORE ORDER, INCREASE
TRUST IN THE INVESTIGATION,
LOWER THE TEMPERATURE.
THE JUDGE ASKED PROSECUTORS,
DOJ, WHAT'S THE HARM?
DO YOU THINK THE TRUMP TEAM IS
RIGHT ON THAT?
>> I THINK THAT'S A CORE
ARGUMENT.
IT DOES CARRY WEIGHT.
WE UNDERSTAND THIS MAY TAKE A
BIT MORE TIME.
EXACTLY, WHAT'S THE HARM?
IT WILL BE DIFFICULT.
IT WILL BE INCONVENIENT FOR YOU,
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, DOJ.
THAT'S LIFE.
DOJ GETS ORDERED TO DO THINGS
THAT ARE DIFFICULT ALL THE TIME.
TRUMP'S ARGUMENT IS WE WILL HAVE
OUR CLIENT'S INTERESTS FULLY
PROTECTS, THE PUBLIC WILL BE
REASSURED.
I'M NOT SURE GIVEN THE TRACK
RECORD THAT DONALD TRUMP'S LEGAL
TIME WILL NOT COMPLAIN ABOUT HIS
RIGHTS BEING VIOLATED EVER AGAIN
IF THEY GET THEIR SPECIAL
MASTER.
THAT IS THE ARGUMENT HERE.
IT COMES DOWN TO ONE OF
CONVENIENCE AND WORKABILITY